yeah there's uh
i mean that's the thing we're struggling
now as a society maybe it'd be nice to
get your
quick comment on that which is um the
people who have traditionally been
powerless
are now you know seeking a fairer
society
a more equal society and
in in attaining more power
justly there's also
a realization at least from my
perspective that
power corrupts everyone even if you're
even if the flag you wave is that of
of justice right and so
you know not to overuse the term but
it'd be nice if you have thoughts about
the whole idea of cancel culture
and the internet
and and twitter and so on where there's
on nuance
difficult discussions of uh of race
of gender of fairness equality
justice all these kinds of things
there's a shouting down
oftentimes of nuanced discussion of
kind of trying to
reason through these very difficult
issues through our history
through what our future looks like do
you have thoughts about the
internet discourse that's going on now
is there something positive
yeah i mean we can pull out of this it's
an interesting thing to see i guess
as you mentioned anytime you're wielding
power
whomever you are doing so carefully is
is important
and it's very very easy to look at the
people that have power
and that are using it poorly or have
used it poorly and go hey you're the bad
guy
and then go well of course if i had
power i'll use it properly and i may
intend to use it properly and maybe i
will but at the same time
we see a lot of times people are people
are people i think that
um a lot of the i think if you if you
believe that that
human beings are all one which i do you
know no matter whether you're here
you're there you're
you're you got two arms two legs a heart
a brain
we all live a similar experience you
know and obviously with variations on a
theme
but uh you know you're no less a human
being if if
you're a person i've never met from
china than than some person
in virginia it's we're all we're all
people and i guess
ultimately if i believe that human
beings are corruptable and that power
corrupts and that
we're all fallible and we say and do
things that
either intentionally or unintentionally
um that we wish we'd not
um i think that
i have to allow for a space i guess with
the word
it's almost a religious term but i guess
i would just say grace and that's
something that i see
disappearing from discourse in the
public or maybe it wasn't there i'm not
sure but it's interesting you know
watching this occur
on the internet because also now no
longer are you and i just having a talk
sitting on a on a bus stop it's now in
writing everything's in writing the
old saying like don't put that in
writing you're like don't put anything
in writing that's how you get in trouble
and basically uh you know with with the
degree to which everything is recorded
but recorded in tiny little bytes it's
very very easy for me to wave
every lesson foolish ignorant incorrect
or correct thing
that someone has ever said or done in
their face to support whatever
argument that i'm trying to make about
them or a situation
and i think that you mentioned cancel
culture or
you know as it seems to exist obviously
this is poisonous on its face this is
poisonous
um it's it's the sort of thing that
doesn't incentivize proper behavior
i mean you look at let's say one of the
great monsters of history adolf hitler
obviously who's done awful awful things
but also for anyone that's
even a minor student of history did some
positive things as well
we don't have to i don't have to
embroider this person's crimes i don't
have to
act as if there was nothing good a
monster has ever done and nothing bad
that
that a great person throughout history
has ever done but imagine the ghost of
adolf hitler were to pop up
and go oh my gosh guys i'm so sorry i i
know what i've done
but i'd like to apologize and start to
make it right well i mean you'd hope
that you
you know if you popped up over here you
go well i don't really like what you've
done
and i don't like you but at the same
time i'm glad to hear that you're
attempting to
make this right and push in a positive
direction even if you can't make it
right
because otherwise what am i doing i'm
disincentivizing change for the better
i'm looking to wield whatever power i
have in a punitive fashion
um which does not encourage people to do
anything other than double down
on on the wrongs that they've made
knowing that at least they're going to
have some support from the people that
support that
and i guess i want to you you would
hopefully
look at the use of the internet as a
tool that can
educate and i guess i don't like the
word empower but empower people to do
various things extend their reach
but uh but educate and learn rather than
to further solidify
little tribal things that exist which i
think everyone in humanity and human
history is vulnerable to me look at the
course of human history it's deeply
tribal and the
tribes or the groups that have been on
top at various points in time have done
a lot of times bad things to the ones
that have not and
you'd hope that we could learn lessons
from the past and rather than
you know committing the crimes that were
you know that were committed
against us recommitting them when we
slide into the top position
um say you know i could do this now but
i'll not you know i understand the urge
to
to seek vengeance is strong of anyone
that says differently i don't i wouldn't
trust
you know but at the same time we go i've
we we have enough
experience in history enough experience
in life enough hopefully wisdom
you know time in to go this isn't the
right answer
this is only going to replay the things
the the worst parts of our history not
the best
and i want to encourage positive
behavior and if i just
again further lash out at people
although understandably
done done understandably i'm simply just
going to just perpetuate the cycle
that's gone on to this point
so you hope that even though we're
seeing a lot of a lot of turmoil
societally at the moment and globally at
the moment that uh
i guess our better angels can prevail at
a certain point but it's going to take a
great deal of leadership and i think
that we're
we're sorely missing like a martin
luther king style character at the
moment or a great leader
and i just i'm hoping that one will show
up
for sure and by the way a word i don't
hear often
and i think it's a beautiful one which
is grace that's a really interesting
word i'm gonna have to think about that
it is there is a religious component to
it but it's exactly right
it um you have to somehow walk the line
between you know you mentioned hitler
i've been reading uh the rise and fall
of the third reich
i'm really thinking about the 1930s
and what what it's like to have uh
economic
my concern is the economic pain that
people are feeling now
quietly is really a suffering
that's not being heard and there's
echoes of that
in the in the 20s and the 30s with the
great depression
and there's a hunger for a charismatic
leader like you said there's a leader
that
could walk with grace could inspire
could uh
could bring people together with uh with
sort of uh
dreams of a better future that's
positive
but hitler did exactly everything that i
just said except for the word positive
which is he did give a dream to the
german people
who were great people who are great
people of
um of a better future it's just that
a certain point that quickly turned
into the better future requires
literally expansion of more land it
started with
well if we want to build a great germany
we need a little bit more land and so we
need to kind of
get austria then we need to kind of get
france mostly because france doesn't
understand that more land is really
useful so we need to get rid of them
and look what they did to us in
versailles anyway
but so the jew the jewish uh
the holocaust is a separate
thing i don't know i don't know i don't
know what to think about
because uh for me being jewish and
having a lot of
the echoes of the suffering is in my
family
of the people that are lost i don't know
because
hitler wrote all about it in mineconf so
i don't know if
the evil he committed was there all
along
i mean and that that's where the
question of forgiveness
i mean hitler's such a difficult person
to talk about but it's the question of
on cancer culture
who is deserving of forgiveness and
who's not
like the holocaust survivors that i've
read about that i've heard the
interviews with
they've often spoken about the fact that
the way for them to let go to overcome
the atrocities that they've experienced
is to forgive like forgiveness
is the way out for them it's interesting
to think about
i i don't know i don't know if i don't
know if we're even a society ready
to even contemplate an idea of
forgiveness for hitler
it's it's an interesting idea though it
was it's a good
thought exercise at the very least to
think about like
all these people that are being canceled
uh
for doing bad things of different
degrees
you think of like louis ck or somebody
like that for being
not a good person but like what is the
path for forgiveness
so what's a good person what is the good
part if that's a sliding scale
that we could all find ourselves looking
at the uncomfortable end of a gun on
you know particularly down the line i
mean you hope for the best but
these definitions i guess like you said
are important and who's doing the
canceling who's being canceled
i'm not necessarily as you said saying
that that's entirely unjustified or
certainly not
it's certainly understandable and
particularly you mentioned like a
monster like an adolf hitler but it's
also interesting i couldn't help but
notice like
you mentioned as a society us being able
to
apply forgiveness to someone who's done
so much horror
but people who are personal i mean of
course many
so many people are personally affected
but directly personally affected someone
a survivor of the holocaust
being able to let go on that i'm nowhere
near big enough a person for that sort
of thing
but i guess that's that's an interesting
thing
you know being the person who was
physically there
potentially able to able to let go
i don't know that's that's unbelievably
powerful it's interesting i guess you
have to
wonder sometimes and this isn't
obviously in regards to that to the
holocaust but
why why i'm holding on to various things
have i
what is it doing for me and what is it
doing to me is it facilitative is it not
and i guess that's something else that i
i really enjoy when i was on ultimate
fighter
they uh they don't let you have um any
music or any books other than religious
text so i brought a bible and i brought
a quran and i started to read them
side by side and it was it was really
interesting reading the bible's a little
drier
quran the crown's more interesting at
least written but um
i think something that was consistently
brought up uh
was the way the
most merciful people want i don't think
any of us want justice
we think we want justice but i don't
think we want justice justice is
dangerous dangerous dangerous game
because maybe this person's wronged me
deeply and i i want justice i want to
balance it out because what is justice
is not a balancing of the scales
and sometimes you can understand it on a
societal level i think it's fine i mean
there's
crime and punishment and we can go for
the benefits and the drawbacks of that
but
i think what any of us want is mercy
within reason
you know grace as you mentioned because
justice is a very very very dangerous
thing
and it's a valuable and important thing
but who gets to decide what's just what
justice is actually meted out maybe i
get to meet out justice but it's not i
don't get my comeuppance well that
sounds great
but what happens when it's pointed back
at me and uh
i i guess that comes back to the veil of
ignorance you know the idea that that
one day i will have to live in the world
in which i've envisioned the world in
which i've created
i i think that a lot of times people
love the idea of uh
they're a judge for your crimes and a
lawyer for theirs and
i heard that the other day i thought it
was great and uh i think that's it
that's a
dangerous thing and hopefully it gives
us all pause before rightly or wrongly
but always understandably you know
wielding wielding
serious power
you